let's go next to yol from ontario canada
y'all you are on the air
can you hear me i can hear you fine
great i've never had a chance to be on
the show this is great um
i wanted to ask a couple questions um
first with the democratic party just for
the state of the union address the other
day
i saw the polls after the
after the address and it showed that
most democrats weren't really favorable
as uh biden's address mostly focused on
foreign policy and not
um
inflation or the economy
why are the democrats so poor
at addressing
issues that are very important to the
american people
and should they be looking to push
people like joe manchin out of the party
because it seems like they're afraid to
offend people
and instead of standing strong for
certain topics
first of all i i don't know that i agree
with the premise from from what i'm
seeing a cbs news poll found that
um
78 of americans
approved of the speech either somewhat
or strongly so i guess the first thing
is i don't know that we're working with
the same information i didn't see
this negative response
this was the polls right act on cnn
right after the state of the union oh
are you saying like on the website of
cnn
um this is i was watching cnn
um do an analysis right after the state
of the union address yeah and i just
went it just and it just went to show
that
i believe um
68 showed they were favorable towards
joe biden's um speeched on foreign
policy toward the ukraine address yeah
and it showed that 48 were satisfied
with his questioning on um on his
address toward
uh the economy and inflation oh okay so
that was like like a topic by topic well
listen i don't know i didn't see that
data and a lot of times in the aftermath
of these speeches these are like very
informal like it's just the people that
vote on our website it usually takes a
while to get something a little more
formal um i mean i think the so i'm not
sure about that i think that um in terms
of uh
you're saying why why aren't democrats
good at addressing issues in a way that
people that resonates with people is
that generally what you're asking yeah
because it just seems like you have
such a
wide fac base
factions in the democratic party it just
seems like someone like joe manchin as
an example doesn't seem like he wants to
play ball what the democrats are trying
to do yeah any meaningful policy pass so
instead of trying to
appeal to him why don't they just try to
either primary him or
um
try in a way to like have the democratic
party stand for something that's solid
it doesn't seem like people really
believe the democratic party stands for
anything or stands by anything strongly
like the republican party does
yeah i i i don't know that i exactly
understand the question you're asking
but i mean i think on joe manchin as
i've said before if you successfully
primary joe manchin that almost
certainly gets flipped and it becomes a
republican seat i believe the solution
is you've got to flip republican seats
you've got to flip republican seats so
that joe manchin doesn't have as much
power and the viability of doing that
this november in the what are going to
be probably tough midterms for democrats
is a real question mark but in terms of
the messaging piece and what the
republican party uh says the democratic
democratic party stands for versus what
the democratic party actually says that
it stands for i have so many different
clips about this and part of this is
messaging part of this is not wanting to
turn people off you don't want to you
don't want to offend any slice of your
party which is impossible if you have
anything beyond an extremely narrow
coalition so this is a long issue for
democrats and i've spoken extensively
about it but i don't think the solution
to all of this is your primary mansion i
think that that one could backfire in
two is it it's too narrow a solution
okay and can i have one more question
just sorry russian ukraine sure um
how much do you think this is actually a
failure of american foreign policy like
long term
are you saying how much is how much is
american foreign policy a cause of
what's happening
sorry yeah that's what i meant yes
um long-term i think that it is uh
i mean the reason this is so tough is
in a
globalized dynamic and complex world
we can't make a statement like
nothing the us has ever done is related
to putin invading ukraine like you that
would be that that would be wrong
obviously
ukraine and russia exist on a planet
where the us has significant influence
but i think we have to be really careful
when we talk about blame
putin decided to do this this was
optional
and it is not the fault of american
foreign policy that putin decided to
invade ukraine and we got to be really
really clear about that yeah the
reasoning why i think of it is like with
us foreign policy it seems a bit
hypocritical in the sense that
um
as an example what separates people are
here bashing vladimir putin for being a
war criminal and i agree
what separates him from george w bush
and then on top of that what separates
as an example what happened with the
cuban missile crisis where there was
hostile weapons put into a neighboring
country and the u.s is ready to invade
them
so isn't there like a massive amount of
hypocrisy in the u.s
of course
i mean listen all of those situations
are different they're not exactly the
same but the main point you're making is
there is always hypocrisy on foreign
policy from countries that have the
types of militaries that do things
around the world the way the the
american military does there's always
some hypocrisy 100 percent
okay that was everything i had to ask
thank you all right thank you so much i
appreciate the phone call
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping